hi come off Bailey department is your
mom home is M your
mom hey how are you you're D get out is
it get out way fine can we speak to
Michaela
sure just a sec sure awesome are you
taking her from we just need to talk to
her real
quick hi Michaela how are you I'm
officer Bailey all right you mind
stepping outside for a
sec you go ahead and turn around for me
can keep turn around for me thank you
put hands on your
back
okay let's go down over here okay I'll
chat with real quick uh can you grab my
shoes shoes right now can we get shes
sure we're just going to hang out down
there real quick walk down yeah we I'll
explain everything to you okay you just
want to walk real quick do do we have
slides or slipper I my he dudes are
downstairs dud the he dudes
okay okay here let me make sure these
are good okay I'll kind of explain
everything okay um so it looks like you
got a warrant okay it's going to be for
child
endangering did you think something like
this was coming down the
pipeline somebody kind of I've talked to
a
detective ago I figed it was quiet yeah
I haven't heard anything in a couple
months sure do you have anything on you
that's going to poke or stick me any
weapons anything like that okay can I
leave my glasses here though yeah
absolutely sure sure
um so we are going to have to place you
under arrest okay we'll take you to
Green
County um is there anything the only
question I have is is Britney IR at said
Green County if so I have no idea okay
that's my sister she was arested from
here and she's not allowed back at the
house okay well it's something I can let
the cosos know so I don't think there's
like a protection order or anything but
um yeah okay well I'll talk to the cos
I'm sure you'll tell talk to the CS2 uh
I'm sure they'll make they'll make room
for it and make sure that that's not
going to be an issue okay okay all right
I'm just going to quickly like make sure
you don't have any weapons on you I'm
not doing a full surgery like that okay
only two pockets you only got two
pockets
okay where the pockets at oh okay I see
them
okay okay
all right you got nothing else on you
okay so I'm just going to warn you right
now um if you do have anything else on
you and they find it at Green County cuz
you're going to have to go through like
a scanner and all that if you have
anything on you that's going to be an
additional charge if you do have
something on you right now we can just
deal with it we can squash it right here
and now okay no there's nothing else
nothing okay is there anything else you
need from inside I know he's going to go
get your shoes um do you have a phone or
a wallet or something that you need I my
phone's on my desk and my wallet's on my
dresser you want those you can leave
them here if you want or you can take
them if you want
I don't think I'd be able to use my
phone but I'd like to have it oh I don't
know what up to you I don't mind you're
you're being okay with me I want to be
okay with you okay um if you want I can
we can get your phone and take that with
us and if you want we can grab your
wallet we can take that with us as well
is that something you want yes please
okay would you mind telling Pen's just
over there you said it's on the desk in
your room yeah my room is downstairs oh
and you want your glasses to stay here
or you want your glasses to go home or
go with you okay phone and wallet and
then could you take these
inside
thanks okay we'll wait for them to get
your shoes before I bring the car around
okay okay um do you have any idea how
long I be here this is legitimately my
first time being in any being any
trouble sort of trouble sure so right
now grab the toil okay thank I'll be
right back and I'll kind of go over some
stuff with you
okay
[Applause]
sh
for
back
3:45 that warrant on hand
crack CLA we'll have her in
custody he said the medicine with an AEG
that has a label on it is in his night
yeah
right got a bag they got prescribe meds
and stuff like that um EV she is and he
is
RAC okay okay driver's license says
I this is the identifying ass thing
gotcha okay that makes sense yeah yeah
so notification to the jail on hey man
that's
cool see that's
cool
you have the meds inside
or they coming back out with it okay his
dad went downstairs to get one out
they all have their turn name on well
this one doesn't and they said it's a
different
P if they don't
have
it these ones
have right right
right there's okay
that would
be well then that's not what was in this
box they're different names no no it
should all be the same name yeah
exactly that's an antibiotic
antibiotics it's a r i p blah blah blah
blah
BL
I'm just prettyy sure it's
a it just doesn't have
a yeah
see
875 yeah here here baby you want to take
the bottle
okay see that's just a weird
thing
recognize i' state for instance you were
driving in your car and
we antic
okay was no prescription okay this
is is that what we're looking for let me
see we that would
on and
then that one's one that he
takes okay so these all three needs to
go let me see this one is
this no that's much that's my ad
okay a r
i this one
is look for I give it a little bottle to
go look and match
up so did he kind of go over with you
was
happening yeah so she is it's called
aable cause warrant um pretty much what
happened with the detectiv gathered
enough evidence brought it to like a
grand jury um and give convinced them
that they wanted to hear the case so
right now it's still the probable cause
phase right which is we take her we take
her to jail there's a warrant out for
her we take her to jail and she's
probably going to see a judge um for
Bond or whatever on Monday okay right
now yeah she doesn't have a bond right
now so there's no bond right now um
until she can see a judge but on Monday
she going to go in the women's section
or the men's SE go in the women
section um just
because I mean I don't I don't know what
the Jail's policy is okay that's not
fairborne what we determine um but I
think if I'm not mistaken and I'm and
I'm not 100% sure on it if I'm not
mistaken if legally like her legal sex
is still female or his legal sex is
still female then byw yeah um so
unfortunately like she would not be or
he would not be allowed to be
I
know not it that's that's the one that
we had I was a
detective
not wait AE it also could be that
no the only one that he's got
so it's if they pull up
his you know if you've got access to his
Walgreens cuz I mean don't really have
access to that he does with his phone
but he ain't going to keep his phone is
he well I mean they have access to the
pharmacy
board the
jail I don't think so well well they
pulled well we got notified our our
young our autistic daughter B that y'
guys just have to come down here she's
been there for a while she's on she's on
the third floor oh okay um yeah I
remember Britney here times fory she's
on the thir she's been she's been a
court a couple times declared her
incompetent and they won't give us
custody because she's well guardianship
guardianship because of the
attacks sister taking her sister's going
to take her gotcha and so that's all in
work right now
attorne 29 yeah so what they're going to
do is is the case she's been fir
incompetent uh they're they're doing
another another
U court date and then do we need to give
him any of
these done but this one
is needs it does is it not it
doesn't name on it well how about I take
it and then if they don't want it and
they kick it back to me and say they
can't um I'm coming back to the city
I'll be here all night I can either drop
it off or I can leave it in the mailbox
if it's late on night or something like
that if you want me to do that that's
fine you want me to go ahead and try do
that I can't drive I just got out
Hospital okay sure well I will I'll try
um I don't think they're going to take
it so I think I'm going to have to back
um if it's too late I'll probably just
put it in if you're okay with it I'll
just drop it in your mailbox it's too
late cuz I don't I don't want you guys
to be waking up at one there's do in the
morning cuz I know with brck they
somehow were able to look cars up and
they wouldn't add on Tylenol and mink
well they do have their own they have
medical staff at the jail it's just not
24 hours um so they may not so they look
it up till tomorrow so they they
probably won't them be able to look it
up
tomorrow has he taken a dose today I
don't know when he takes it great
talking can't bond or anything like that
Monday morning you will see and they
will
determine that'll all be
done if you bond out tonight if you get
a hold of a bail bond and you pay that
Bond they isue tonight with our court
dat whatever he gives you on your paper
okay
but
that I would wait until you hear him
because have to the bond huh who will
set the bond so the warrant should have
the bond set I didn't think that it let
me go check and make let me go check and
see if there's a bond set
okay all
right
we'll get in on this
side is there any way I can have this
PCH to the
Frank um if possible if
not yeah we can do that that's fine I
don't mind doing that at all you've been
fine with
us
um do we need to leave this here if you
want to take it off we can leave it here
but the Jail's going to take it and put
it in your property if you don't
you'll have it when you get out of the
jail nobody's going to steal it from you
okay he from cuz that thing was 80 bucks
yeah all right go ahead and take a
seat you all right y
just